hi guys guess whose birthday is coming
up real soon mine Barry through there
please release the balloons
I don't know I'm acting like Barry's den
is in heaven Barry if you can hear me
please send down a ghost balloon whoa
whoa so anyway yes my birthday is coming
up on June 28th I'm gonna be turning 25
years old a lot of people don't know
what my actual ages but yes also if you
did the math yes you are correct
Bob's wedding is also on the 28th of
June and I'm gonna be going back to
Cincinnati I'm gonna be going back to
Cincinnati uh Wednesday so that I can
spend time with my family go to Bob's
wedding hang out with my brother again
and my old friends and my mom really
wants to see me really badly so I'm
gonna be going back home and while I'm
home I'll have my old recording set up
there so I'm hoping to be able to record
videos while I'm away I've been so busy
that I haven't been able to pre record
videos and hopefully you guys are gonna
be okay if there's occasionally one
video a day throughout the time that
I've gone but remember it is my birthday
so maybe I could do the thing the thing
that I'm most worried about is because
over the past two years I've done a
charity livestream on my birthday for
the town past two years literally on the
day on my birthday and I'm not gonna be
able to do this year I greatly apologize
for that
and I'm going to be going to a wedding
instead so if you count that as good or
better I don't really care all so I'm
hoping that people notice that each vlog
I do my hair gets progressively weirder
so I'm gonna fix that up right now oh
god it's all goopy
I think it's kind of big foam Oh Oh God
uh-huh it's goopy why is it gonna be Oh
what are we doing it look good look good
how's that a little better little faux
hockey is it good yet
that's more like it I think that people
are gonna like my new style it seems
weird that my hair is a point of debate
amongst the fandom ah it's getting
crusty Oh who's in that stuff
it sounded like eight years old I don't
know when I had it either way so anyway
that's all I got to say for this one um
just I'm gonna be out of town it's gonna
be my birthday I'm getting older every
year I feel there every year and I'm
gonna have a fun time while I'm back
home because I'm gonna go hang out with
a bunch of friends I'm gonna see Wade
and Bob again and then we're gonna have
a grand old time I don't know if we were
gonna have time to record things
together remember Bobby's getting
married that means he's his his life is
dedicated towards a woman his wife but I
mean dedica with Carrie vision that
means his life is now dedicated towards
the wedding and making it even better so
hope you guys understand that while that
happens because I don't know if we're
gonna be able to record but I really
hope that we'll be able to get at least
one video maybe wait it'll be free but I
don't know no promises guys so anyway
I'm gonna be getting back on the 30th of
June just some time for July to start
and do remember that charity livestream
is coming up on the 12th of July do not
miss it I'm gonna be starting 9:00 a.m.
but the time is different because I'm
over on the Pacific coast so that's 9
a.m. Pacific Standard Time which is
actually 12 that's actually noon on the
eastern coast of the world also known as
Eastern Standard captain noon EST 5
o'clock in the evening probably for you
Englanders out there and the rest of the
world I don't know you the internet can
tell you the answer because I can't do
math right now my brain is not working
the chemicals from my hair product are
getting into my face and I don't feel
too good I really feel a lot dumber than
when I started this that's usually how I
feel when I record videos
so anyway that's all I got for this vlog
thank you all so much for watching um
it's a been amazing some of the videos
that you guys have been watching have
just been doing phenomenally the baby
plyer animation just crossed a million
views that's a fastest of videos ever
gotten to a million views thank you guys
so much for your amazing support over
the past few weeks thank you for just
being the most awesome fans of you can
be I really want this to be a community
that rallies around these great projects
like charity and just you know doing
better in your own life just being nicer
to people and going out of your way to
make your friends feel better because
you never know when they're having a bad
day so try to spread some happiness I
did a tweet to that effect and also I'm
not going to kill myself I hope people
know that but I am gonna go under into
the desert and pet doggies who seem
foaming at the mouth for some strange
reason also look into weird water
bottles that are shaped like guns
love that so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye